et alors renaud revel est avec nous et
donc et dans le parisien d'aujourd'hui
et il ya eu un compte rendu de
l'audition de textes aux prud'hommes
cette audition donc s'est tenue hier et
oppose donc l'ancien animateur comme l'a
dit d amour à la société production de
jeux sony pictures rappelle donc texte
réclame 1,2 million d'euros à sony
pictures c'est ça la boîte de prod
une somme qui correspond à deux ans de
salaire et à des indemnités bien sûr
zone euro dès la première question
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au procès
guerre aux renault mais je suis est donc
le conflit qui oppose france 2 sony
pictures et textes rien et durant le
procès les avocats de sony pictures ont
voulu produire effectivement ce que vous
avez vous quelques minutes à savoir des
propos graveleux qu'il aurait tenus hors
antenne
alors c'est à dire sur le plateau la
production a enregistré tex et amener
ces enregistrements à l'audience ils ont
se servir de ça contre texte absolument
c'est comme les cafetières quoi noual
s'arrête demain
merci mes propos vous pouvez tenir ici
hors antenne pendant les coupures de pub
mais le conte est exploité enregistré
est donc amené effectivement lors de
l'audience la juge qui est qui dirigeait
le la séance en question estimé que ces
propos là n'étaient pas exploitables
juridiquement parce que j'étais hors
sujet c'est ça mon texte parce que ce
n'était pas le but effectivement de
l'audience en question qui ne statuer
que sur le conflit qui oppose sony
pictures et le texte entre parenthèses
co2 c'est honteux de la part de la prod
d'avoir fait ce que je trouve ça
choquant ça c'est sûr c'est vrai mais
voilà moyens on cautionne pas voilà
aussi les non bien sûr mais se sont
imaginé si on utilise tous les halls à
abattre et nous laisser un big brother
généralisée et s'abaissent le train
comme transparence de la société c'est
tout ce qu'on veut demain qu'un avocat
d'ailleurs n'a aucun doute a dit la
chose suivante c'est que ces propos là
hors contexte ils sont forcément
interprété qu'une phrase comme
s'activent jeté en pâture sans le mettre
dans le cortège en question c'est
terrible pour les gens qu'ils ont et
paraît que ça n'est pas recevable
donc pour autant recevable il semble en
plus qu'il n'est pas enregistré
l'audition texte propos m'ont dit qu'ils
auraient pris son iphone dès qu'il
aurait pris en note simplement que les
extraits de l'audio est ce qui lui était
reproché d'enregistrer l'audience qui
est complètement qui seront motorisés et
donc
et voilà et donc texte vous faisais
juste reprenez les autres donc l etat y
est exactement
moi je les beautés de vote ce matin il
fait fondre est forcément parce que ce
sont des coups sa femme a découvert tous
à sa famille également
alors déjà qu'il y avait un précédent
effectivement que julien courbet
là c'est terrible en terme d'image et en
termes de carrière c'est calamiteux donc
il est il effectue réseau postal famille
voilà c'est ce qui nous a dit un
responsable sous écoute autant lorsqu'il
a dit à la production il a dit voilà il
a dit quoi la safam cas c'est bien sûr
pour sa famille c'est assez compliqué
critiqué dit oui alors moi j'ai eu un
spécialiste des prud'hommes pour savoir
aussi comment ça se passe et est ce que
le fait qu'il aurait enregistré moi je
serai c'est sur cette version
l'audience est ce que ça serait
exploitable on m'a dit que non ça
pourrait seulement peut-être mettre de
mauvaise humeur les jugent injuste de
mauvaise humeur c'est jamais bon signe
non gaza ne peut pas rentrer en bus à
mon avis doit être une mauvaise humeur
parce que le juge par rapport à ce qu'a
fait aussi la production de
l'enregistrer palatial rixe était
irrecevable
voilà c'est irrecevable mais le fait
effectivement c'est scandaleux
effectivement c'est une atteinte à la
vie privée on ne peut pas faire ça
le l'avocat lui d'après ce qu'on m'a dit
pourrait éventuellement se retourner
aussi contre la production qui a produit
cela est allé au pénal on ne peut pas
être jugé dans ce tribunal
professionnelle mais ça peut être jugé
au pénal dernier point sur le csa
puisque le csa a été interpellé dans le
parisien le csa n'a pas les moyens
d'agir sur des roches qui n'ont pas été
diffusés allemagne en revanche le csa a
disculpé
si vous permettez ses huit de ces propos
qui étaient tenus avant la divette
merci oui et le fait que ce soient pas
redevables ça change pas grand chose le
mal est fait à partir on les juges ont
entendu les fera passer dans la tête et
ça restera maintenant il faut